every single day i get asked some
variation of evan i'm lazy how do i get
out of it evan i'm procrastinating how
do i get out of it one you don't call
yourself a lazy person there's no such
thing as a lazy person if you are
procrastinating or you're being lazy
right you are being lazy doesn't mean
that you are a lazy person there's two
reasons why you're doing it there's two
reasons why you are being lazy one
you don't have a dream that's big enough
you don't have something that inspires
you you don't want to get out of bed in
the morning if i was an accountant i
would be a really lazy accountant i
would hate my life not to knock
accountants it's just not for me if i
was a video editor
i would be i would be lazy i would hate
my life i don't want to be a video
editor i don't want to be an accountant
actually there's most things in the
world that i don't want to be and if you
forced me to do that i would be lazy
that's 95 of america i think 95 of
america wakes up and drive to a job that
they hate
and then they're lazy there